what's happening there reject nation we
have made it to the finale part one of
stranger things season four and this is
also part one of our reaction to
stranger things for uh the finale
because this is a long long episode i'm
ready to chew it all up right now
uh so yeah i have to cut it up into two
parts if you want to watch part two if
it's up now there's a card here's a link
of in the pin comment or something when
it when it's up in case this is the
first one you're watching but in the
meantime i want to say thank you to
everyone who joined our patreon page
became a super sexy reject full-length
watch launch we single with the time
code for stranger things and a bunch of
other shows with his exclusive reaction
highlights over at our patreon page and
uh please leave a like that would be
very much appreciated and subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when our next video is up and
thank you to the boys at prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
would not have been able to do this
without your help with all the things we
have to cover and also on top of moving
so
yeah let's get to it guys it's a big one
oh
they made it
[Music]
god they're like face huggers with wings
oh god
[Music]
this is their monster effects runner
[Music]
what do we call these demo bats
demodactyls
[Music]
oh
wow
stephen steve
see jesus christ oh my god
twice
he's going to buy to bite the head off
one of those things at some point
there's not that many
that's demented music hope you remember
your way back
oh my god they're really gonna explore
the upside down
i'm so excited
hell on earth
this poor cop
just don't kill killer
justice for faceless agent guy who
helped us number
two going back to the strong coke cans
the door is always open
this place
is not a prison
this is
you could learn a lot from this john i'm
taking notes
and what exactly were you all doing at
the lake
watch pork having beers going for a walk
a walk at 9pm to the lake
take a little swim
how's that coming
and nancy was she with you at this night
swim no
yes oh we're not sure
[Laughter]
nope no we have we haven't heard
absolutely we barely know the guy who oh
that's a bunch of bulls erica i mean you
realize they're lying the whole couch is
on fire
shut up
that was the day he became a true
sheriff
this eddie guys just had the worst week
ever
it's racked up so much trauma in such a
small amount of time
jesus i'm fine i'm fine no no no no no
you're not you're losing blood
oh no oh what's happening you ready yeah
just do it
gooey
well we don't have to go all the way
downtown for guns
i have guns
in my bedroom lots of guns
a russian macarov and a revolver yeah
you almost shot me with that one
you almost deserved it
you guys are so cute together
yeah so gun seemed like a pretty good
idea to me
[Laughter]
lots of guns
even if we somehow kill this beast we
still must escape
we fail there
i don't think they will be so kind as to
throw us back in the cell they will
shoot us on site we die as monster
slayers
it must be hardwired into us to reject
our fathers
so we can grow move on
[Music]
become something of our own
i hope that's what she's doing
coming into her own
you have no idea man
well maybe i should give that prayer
thing a try
if we want to get out of here i'm going
to get back to ellen mikhail you and me
we're going to need a miracle
hey man monsters and a hellscape exist
why not god
you guys can beat it
[Laughter]
hey
last night your sister 11 suffered a
concussion
during her alone time in the rainbow
room oh those guys all deserve to die
someone did this
who's going to tell me what happened
you've seen her papa
she's
clumsy
stupid
you're very pleased with yourself you
guys are not coy
[Laughter]
i'm going to
murder these children before you right
now
let this be a lesson to you all
damn justice is getting served
the hell are you gonna do brenner
what happened
it was an accident
[Music]
[Music]
catholic school all over again
i've been through worse
henderson told me you were a badass
kid worships you dude like
you have no idea
it's kind of annoying to be honest
i don't even know why i care what that
little shrimp thinks but uh he has that
effect
outside of d d i am no hero
we don't know about that the wheeler
right there
she didn't waste a second
she just dove right in
i would get her back
is that this has
unambiguous sign of true love
[Laughter]
[Music]
are we back at the trailer park you
don't think they went through through
watergate
without us without a plan without
weapons
they wouldn't be that stupid please
here's the deal
either you tell me what's happening
or i told dustin what i found under your
bed
please no spill your guts
photos of mike
serial killer is a dark wizard from the
upside down and we've been looking for
him but he's in the upside down which we
can't reach at least we thought we
couldn't until we found a gate at lovers
lake that was the reason why we were
[Laughter]
so what if with each kill he's not
simply killing them he's making a
powerful psychic connection with his
victims a connection powerful enough to
rip a hole in the fabric of time and
space
he's opening more gates
oh damn more gates
oh why would he be opening gates to take
over the world who do we know that wants
to take over the world the mind players
so if the demogorgon was just his foot
soldier feckness his five-star general
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that was incomprehensible you
lost me at mother gate please be kind
rewind
oh no
oh
no
or maybe it's our friends
oh that's right
those aren't guns
i threw these away years ago
[Music]
is it frozen in time
those are the cards of steve yeah hey
these are from sophomore chemistry
and this
this wallpaper this this is old
wallpaper time travel yeah
this diary should be full of entries
it's not the last entry is november 6
1983.
the day will went missing
the day the gate open
we're in the past cool
dustin
dustin dustin
all right either this kid can't hear us
or he's being a total douchebag
you need a communication device
lights
[Music]
what are you getting at
[Music]
that's beautiful
[Music]
there you go dusty bun
hey uh
remember when i said they wouldn't be
stupid enough to go through watergate
beautiful present you got here
how about this
how about that huh you look so goopy
so nice to meet you uh i'm yuri of
course but allow me to introduce you to
my favorite
oh my god
we are we are so close
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh we are laughing
and we are friends
you russians have good dry comedic
timing
it's the official comedy of the
motherland
would be 18
my dude
let us hope your prayers have been heard
again come on
he's being watched now but once he is
released he and the others are going to
attempt to kill you
right here they don't even realize it
but he is moving them like
pieces on this board here this is a
metaphor
you frighten him and he also knows he
can't control you
i saw all this happening that's why i
wanted to help you but i only made
things worse
helping me
made papa hurt you
or this is all part of papa's plan why
do you still help
because i believe in you
i really want to believe in you too dude
wow
this is an important ass character then
yeah so this is the day she like that
led into season one
yeah hey
[Music]
ah smart the light bright oh cool
[Music]
oh my god light brights are gonna be so
back in style after this
okay you guys seeing this
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
oh
cool
that's so cool
hi
hi that worked
my mind went too stupid
uh you can't get back through watergate
[Music]
perfect yes yes yes okay we think we
have a theory that can help with that
genius
genius child
how many times do i have to be right on
the money before you guys just trust me
jesus christ this kid's got to get his
econ check it's his tone right
[Laughter]
dustin's two surrogate dads completely
creepily frozen in time and [ __ ] but
haven't you always had bikes
the four kids had bikes too
[Music]
led officer callahan
[Music]
[Laughter]
i guess it's just a minor misdemeanor
[Music]
that's a poster right there too
oh that's so cool nice
this is kind of like the poster with all
the different roads leading to
the inevitable
how are you feeling today
okay
are you up for some more lessons
he's got like an evil abraham lincoln
thing about him
[Laughter]
boy sounds like daniel day lewis's room
yeah thank you
the light is hurting my head she says
she's still dizzy lights are hurting her
hurting whoo
oh no
oh this is the same night she got away
i don't think so not without that
massacre this will lead you out beyond
the laugh fence to the woods
can you feel it
it weakens me tracks me even if there
were another way out he will find me and
if he finds me he will find you
you help me i help you
you still can't fit through that hole i
mean maybe she could do something about
the hole
this is a [ __ ] horrifying man yeah
this is so scary
okay
oh just you wait my dude
come on hopper come on hopper light it
on fire
i wonder how much bigger it's gotten
yeah it's uh
last season finale be a sumo gorgon
cause the fight
oh boy
oh buddy boy
i've been built up all season it's
goddamn
[Music]
then i'm afraid you're going to have to
kill me
because your friend is already dead come
on
come on
oh man
oh my god oh
it's been a minute oh
oh
jesus
get it
oh come on guys
[Music]
this is
oh my god that flame's going out i
know ah
there's some poetic irony twice we have
no idea what these buttons do you can't
just press away like we got no choice
man come on
it was a choice
when i get out of here i swear to god
jesus of course
[Music]
oh nice
[Music]
i throw javelin in my spare time please
don't tell me as i was injured
your angel
your miracle angel
your miracle angel
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh i can't move it guys
that's sorry
it's that's what i meant
[Music]
hey guys that's the end of our stranger
things finale part one reaction part two
should be up in like two to three hours
or depending on the time you're watching
this it's already up and there's a card
right above you or there's an end screen
right here
[Music]
you